we covered a lot of ground in this
lesson you've learned about user
research which allows you to figure out
what users needs are what they say they
want and how they use existing products
we also learned about validating your
idea through market demands trends and
competitive analysis sometimes as you
validate your original idea might change
or be scrapped and that's okay
like any good entrepreneur you have to
continue validating your hunches once
you had a validate idea and something
users want you'll need to deliver a
product to the end-user will cover how
to think about your users and how to
design great experiences for them in the
next lesson